what's going on guys
that's my famous turkey impression
because it's Thanksgiving here in
America you know Thanksgiving
commemorating the first ever gigantic
meal eaten in America and because it's
Thanksgiving we're thinkin huh is there
some stuff that we're thankful for and
TV and movies the answer is yeah so
we're taking a break from chowing down
on grandma's stuffing and givin thanks
to some of our favorite people and
things and TV and movies so unbutton
your pants sit back and enjoy the ride
that unbutton your pants is because
you're full not a sex thing unless you
wanted to thank you two key & peele for
five years of awesome sketch comedy and
for giving a chance to a young hungry
fresh-faced comedian to shine on the
small screen twice thank you to Straight
Outta Compton love and mercy and San
Andreas
for giving us this summer's Jamaat
essence not since the makan asan's has
an actor so deserved to have his name
matched up with Renaissance thank you to
select theater owners who are keeping
their movie theaters open 24 hours a day
opening weekend of Star Wars The Force
awakens I'm seeing it at 4 a.m. opening
night awesome for me crappy for the kids
selling popcorn gotta say thanks to Sir
Ian McKellen's mr. Holmes for finally
giving us a filmed adaptation of famed
literary detective Sherlock Holmes
here's hoping this movie spawns dozens
and dozens of other adaptations of the
famed super sleuth imagine if mr. Watson
could be played by Lucy Liu one day
thank you to the crew of HBO's the jinx
for leaving the mic and the sound
recording while Robert Durst left and
went to the bathroom best use of an open
mic in a bathroom since the Naked Gun
thank you George Miller at 70 years old
you unretired for making action movies
and gave us Mad Max fury road thank you
for making this and not Happy Feet 3
although if you gave a penguin an
electric guitar no no no just no that
doesn't mean anything
thank you lethal weapon after terminator
genisys you and Rambo are the only
cornerstone 80s action franchises not to
put out a pg-13 reboot or sequel I love
you Riggs and Murtaugh but I never want
to see you again just good thank you
England for not deporting me when I came
to your great and proud country and
proceeded to do nothing but make the
dumbest Austin Powers jokes yeah baby
yeah
who is well within your rights to kick
me back across the pond but you know
what you were classy and you let me stay
and then I made a lot of mean comments
about me in the youtube comment section
I'm a real wanker Thank You mr. robot
for being my first show since the wire
that I watch but none of my friends or
family have seen it or maybe even heard
of it yet it's like Fight Club meets the
social network that's what I say to
people thank you Shia LaBeouf just when
we started thinking of you as a serious
actor you go and release one of the best
viral videos of the year you little
scamp just do it whenever you have a
crazy idea like yelling in front of a
green screen or sitting in a movie
theater and watching all of your movies
please follow your own advice and just
true
thank you to bing-bong for being one of
my favorite movie characters of the
summer and for making every adult who
saw inside out feel guilty for
abandoning their childhood am I too old
to have an imaginary friend let me know
in the comments below thanks to the boy
next door and JLo for showing us that
women can have the same age discrepancy
with a love interest as men do except
when men do it it's a romantic comedy
when women do it it's a psychological
murder thriller Thank You Bryce Dallas
Howard high heels for giving nerds
something to debate about all summer not
since Quentin Tarantino shot a barefoot
uma Thurman as so much attention been
paid to one woman's feet I applaud you
for running from that t-rex and high
heels that is something I could never do
I have tried and finally got to give a
big thanks to you our fans this has been
a huge year for screen junkies and none
of it would be possible without you guys
so from the bottom of my heart thank you
so much so thank you
Devin Coulson Jamie Rodgers Travis of
Marvel Rudy Vasquez arms still hereas
thank you so much everyone who's part of
the screen junkies family we love you so
what are you most thankful for this year
tell us in the comments section below
best answer we're gonna send you a
screen junkies t-shirt I want to thank
you again for watching screen junkies
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter
Happy Thanksgiving
bye bye is Jar Jar like a dark genius
movies if this was true and you found
out that Jar Jar Binks was a villain
inhabitance in the force awakens in a
month from now riots